this morning for our series the dish one
of my favorites we are visiting an
award-winning Thai restaurant attracting
diners all across New England the
restaurant is called sap and you can
find it in the village of Randolph
Vermont it is run by Chef Nisa Sean
ruing Morgan and her husband Chef Steve
Morgan she recently won the title of
best chef in the Northeast from the
prestigious James Beard Foundation Jan
Crawford went to Vermont to find out
what makes sap so special
in this small town in central Vermont on
top of a hill and an historic Victorian
home is a revelation
here in this tiny kitchen with this
well-worn stove critically acclaimed
Chef Nisa Sean room Morgan is creating
some of the best Thai food in America
fish sauce her kitchen staff totals one
husband and co-chef Steve Morgan when
you come into this restaurant you're
cooking and you're the line cook yeah we
cook together you're the boss in the
kitchen
every ingredient room selects for its
authenticity every dish she makes to
order skills she learned cooking and
restaurants in Bangkok she and Morgan
met online more than a decade ago
connecting over their shared love of
food to be together rule moved a world
away it must have been hard at first to
settle here I lie but I don't like cold
I like Vermont but not cold yeah I don't
like home but I like here I like you
know you've built a life here yeah
blending their families cooking the
foods room loved was also her connection
to home and then inspiration I was like
honey you should open your own
restaurant I think we would do well and
if you cook food from home people will
travel here for it so how did you feel
about having a restaurant I am happy you
know I don't have to thinking about I
work for somebody you know you work for
yourself now not for somebody else
the distinctive flavors and dishes are
inspired by food room made and ate
growing up in the isan region in
Northern Thailand it was there during a
visit the couple came up with the
restaurant's name we were sitting up in
her mom's house probably 13 of us
sitting around a table eating and
everybody was saying
when we eat food together with family
all these sap all these sap and what
does it
means delicious yeah
so sap and esign means delicious and
that's the name of this restaurant yeah
but it also means something in Vermont
you know because there's syrup right sap
everywhere making maple syrup from sap
and so it made sense
there's no maple syrup it's sap all the
dishes the stir fries Seafood salads and
soups are authentic to runes region of
Thailand with a few additions because
Rune insisted that's what Americans
would want I never cooked
so some of the things that we think of
here in America as being Thai food it's
not at all the kind of food that you
grew up with
nope no pad thai no we fought a little
bit at the beginning you fought at the
beginning because I was like we're not
going to have Pad Thai on the menu oh
you want it to be more authentic yeah so
you're like no pad thai none of these
Americanized dishes but you said we want
dishes Americans want to eat I think
because because I think American people
love Pad Thai but I want this to be my
last meal when I die Bruce Johnson told
us he's eaten it sap more than a hundred
times driving almost an hour each way
how's it different than a Thai
restaurant it's not only home style
cooking but she cooks before she has
room's talents now have taken her places
she never could have imagined
tell me when you got nominated for the
James Beard award did you ever think you
would win
I don't know how big how that now I
didn't realize it yeah I I don't know
but my husband will be
[Applause]
okay
you won my husband crying
she is the first person in Vermont to
win best chef in the Northeast the award
validated her belief if you cook what
you love people will come you've totally
improved on everything
you think it's familiar and then you
taste and you're like I've never tasted
anything like that before yeah it's
amazing it's delicious
what's up
sap
for CBS mornings I'm Jan Crawford in
Randolph Vermont
where you'd expect to find it but sap
means delicious and that food certainly
looks delicious best new Chef in the
Northeast big honor you're watching CBS
mornings we'll be right back